will smith fish is scary okay i'm just
putting out there right now will smith
as a fish is disgusting it's
gross i don't like looking at the idea
that the main character is just
idiotic oh and the movie shark tail it
really blows yeah a good chunk of that
comes from the fact that oh just look at
the design of this thing it's ah what
kind of movie would allow a design like
this to exist well that's one of the
main problems with the movie it just
sort of seems like a dumb idea from the
start like maybe it could be a little
imaginative but it seems more like an
excuse to make a popular soundtrack with
a lot of artists on it and to shout a
lot of catchphrases and promote a lot in
jokes and AH some really horrible puns
I'm Katie current get out those shell
phones and comment to the boss I'm not
gonna lie out of all the DreamWorks
animated movies this one feels like the
worst it just feels like something that
was created from marketing surveys like
what are the kids liking nowadays well
they like fish and they like Will Smith
throw that together throw it some
pop culture phrases and you have uh
alright alright let's look at the story
Will Smith fish yeah that's why I'm
calling him I know the character has a
name but it you're never gonna call
Knight you're just gonna call
Will Smith fish he's a fun happening
kind of guy who's being admired by Renee
Zellweger fish again I'm sure has a name
but it's just Renee Zellweger has a fish
he works at a whale wash instead of a
car wash not to be fair that's a check
have a clever idea but things get out of
hand when his boss played by Martin
Scorsese fish orders him to be axed
because he couldn't pay the amount of
money that he owed we're
misunderstanding Will Smith fish seems
to have killed a shark which suddenly
turns him into a hero making everybody
think that he's now the sharkslayer and
as long as he doesn't let anyone know
that it was all just a mistake he
remains the town hero but somewhere
across the sea Robert DeNiro shark is
having troubles with Jack Black shark
they belong to some sort of shark mafia
that Robert De Niro shark is the head of
but Jack Black shark is a vegetarian and
doesn't like eating fish which is a big
letdown to father Robert De Niro shark
so to escape the family life he
makes a deal with Will Smith fish
they'll make it look like Will Smith
fish kills jack black shark and thus he
can disguise himself as a dolphin and
start a new life over blending in with
the rest of his fishy buddies the
problems in this movie seem pretty
obvious and yeah they are a lot of
dialogue is just catch phrases in jokes
and puns and on top of that you almost
never see these characters as actual
characters you just see the celebrities
representing them also you know my
hatred for the whole liar revealed story
and well this one doesn't follow it
quite exactly it has a lot of the same
elements and still doesn't throw in that
many surprises let me put this way
there's still a lot of moping and doping
it just doesn't happen after he reveals
the lie so we still get those really
boring scenes that you don't give a
about I'll give it credit that's some of
the actors they choose were unique
choices and yeah sometimes the
delivery's can get a laugh particularly
off Martin Scorsese and Robert De Niro
but Wilson it doesn't bring anything
that he couldn't bring to any other role
Rene Zellweger is a pretty pointless
choice Jack Black has an incredibly
annoying voice in this even Angelina
Jolie fish I forgot to mention her a lot
you know they just picked him because of
the names and no other reason and on top
of it here's another big problem with
the movie I think the Will Smith fish is
too stupid and too selfish I mean we
know he's gonna do the right thing in
the end but Rene Zellweger fish gives
him a pearl that I guess her mother her
grandmother gave her that supposed to be
worth a lot and that's gonna get him out
of debt what does he do he doesn't pay
off the debt he goes to the races and
bets it okay that's not a charming
little mistake that is a dick move and
there's a couple times he does stuff
like that something where he's supposed
to be dependable but it's not like a
funny little mistake or something clumsy
gets in the way he makes a choice and
they're usually very dickish choices so
yeah for me I couldn't find much to like
in this film I thought the underwater
world wasn't that creative the
celebrities were mostly pointless the
puns insufferable sometimes I get a
laugh but got the longer I had to look
at Will Smith fish the quicker I want to
turn it off and I suggest you get the
jump on turning it off before you even
start watching it